we live in a society of reboots where
Hollywood is running out of ideas so
they just remake old stuff but sometimes
there are reboots and reimaginings that
I actually want Babylon 5 Highlander two
projects I would love to see remade and
one other one that's been rumored for
quite a while
Farscape
hmm welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and movie channel
[Music]
in 1999 we got Farscape on our
television screens and this was a series
that genuinely proper sci-fi fans adored
it's actually regularly tops polls of
sci-fi channels best TV shows ever and
regularly appears on top 10 best sci-fi
series ever it was done in co-production
between Hallmark and Jim Henson
Productions and we got to see a lot of
Jim Henson's work in the series
obviously Jim Henson is the master of
puppetry and his son Brian Henson has
carried on that tradition admirably I
actually loved that element of the show
and we got to see makeup and puppets
that really we didn't get to see in many
other things it felt very much like a
Henson TV show and that's one of the
reasons why I loved it now Jim Henson
and his companies obviously famous for
more child related things obviously the
Muppets now if you are a regular side
tracker you will know that one of our
very committed fans uh Shelley is a
massive Muppets one and if you go on our
Facebook page and scroll down you will
see lots of Muppet related images
because we love Shelley she loves
Muppets so we provide her with as much
Muppet related content as we can I
personally and I'm massive Muppets fan
it's the chef
[Music]
I just love the chef and animal as well
I've he was always my favorite
guy why don't you tell her audience how
long have you been playing the drums uh
one two
fine
but they also did things like Fraggle
Rock down at Fraggle Rock
[Music]
great TV show again one of my favorites
when I was a kid with some brilliant
movies over the years like Dark Crystal
and obviously Sesame Street with the
count oh greetings it is hard to count
and it's time to answer that fascinating
question what is the Sesame Street
number of the day
one oh
just you know I just we all grew up with
Jim Henson and fast game was their
attempt at making a proper grown-up
Sci-Fi show and my god did it work
but is there a plan to reboot the series
and bring it back
now apparently this has been rumored for
quite some time I've actually heard this
rumor several times over the last year
I've got to the point now where I can
tell you this rumor because
I think it's a bit more than a room I
think it's fair to say that Brian Henson
and Brian Henson's company has been
trying to reboot Farscape whether
they're going to be successful or not
we'll come back to in a minute but I'd
just like to give you a little bit of a
history of Brian Henson and Jim Henson's
company over the last few years so the
company was actually started in 1958 by
Jim and Jane Henson they obviously
brought us all of those amazing shows I
discussed a few minutes ago as well as
some amazing movies and also they
provided the puppets and the puppetry
work for lots of amazing movies they
also now own a recording studio where I
mean honestly go and have a look at the
list of some of the albums that have
been recorded at Jim Henson's Studios
they're phenomenal they're obviously
masters of sound and I just love it they
still have a creative workshop and they
still do a lot of puppetry work for lots
of TV shows and movies and they're
obviously still doing a few different
television shows but
Disney on The Muppets now
um Brian Henson's company sold it to
them in 2004 along with Bear in the Big
Blue House now could Farscape actually
return
it's difficult now again like to say
I've heard this from several different
sources
um I've actually heard Whispers that
even some of the actors from the show
have been discussing the possibility now
this had some great actors Ben Browder
and Claudia Black then joined sg1 after
the um Peacekeeper Series in 2004 the
relationship between Viola and Daniel
for example was just some of the best
bits of those last two series their love
hate relationship and some of the comedy
we then got because of that relationship
was just glorious the will they weren't
they in those two seasons was amazing
and then we got to see that relationship
come to fruition if only for a short
period when they were stuck on a ship in
that time vortex
now we can hope that time would have
repeated itself and that relationship
would have blossomed once again
but if it didn't at least it did in that
little bubble of time
I would love Ben Browder and Claudia
Black to return and I would actually
love Farscape to not be a hard reboot
but a continuation of the story a
Revival of the series
it's very fashionable at the moment two
Revival series as it has been for quite
some time and if you're going to revise
a series like this I'd love the Sci-Fi
Network to get on it
but there is a major problem
the IP the intellectual property who
actually owns Farscape is a little bit
of a Minefield so it was co-produced as
I said by Hallmark and Brian Henson
Productions now Brian Henson Productions
has gone through quite a few changes in
the last few years and Hallmark well
they're not the PowerHouse they were a
few years ago there is also a little bit
of a problem because there is an
Australian Network involved as well and
they might own certain elements of the
rights
so who owns the rights is the major
problem and then who would Finance the
project is the next this obviously seems
to mean like a show that would go on to
something like the Sci-Fi network but
the Sci-Fi Network don't have the money
to produce a TV show to a decent
standard is my feeling I'm looking at
the arc a recent television series
um written by Dean Devlin and um
Jonathan Glassner you would think that
would get a decent budget but to be
honest even though I quite like the
story and I even quite like the actors
the budget is a problem now I actually
released a short video just saying hey
this isn't a bad show give it a go I
watched the opening episode but I did
say look the budget is a problem you're
gonna have to look past it but to be
honest as the episodes have gone on it's
become more of a problem it's becoming
harder to look past now Farscape was
never a big budget project it's a bit
like Babylon 5 it's got a cult following
that saw past that but they really were
able to maximize everything they could
they put every dollar of their budget on
the screen and if this was to be done by
the Sci-Fi Network they'd have to do
that again
now I'd have thought this would go to a
streaming service I could see something
like Apple TV snapping this up or even
Amazon Prime the problem is the
streaming service Wars that we've had in
the last few years is coming to an end
they are being far more careful what
they spend money on and I can't see a
streaming service risk in this
look at the problems that J micro
zazinski is having getting this Babylon
5 reimagining up and running
he's having massive problems and one of
the main reasons is money nobody quite
has the trust in a Babylon 5 reboot to
actually put their money where their
mouth is now I've heard rumors very
recently they've actually Warner
Brothers is going to do that and it will
go into HBO Max so maybe that gives
Farscape a chance to if Babylon 5 was to
return and be successful maybe that
would give somebody else the confidence
to put a few million quid up and give
Farscape a chance too now everything
I've heard recently is that this is one
of those projects that even though Brian
Henson would absolutely adore the chance
to do it really is hitting a brick wall
if we want a Farscape Revival we're
going to have to talk about it we're
going to have to tweet and we're going
to have to get people interested
because at the moment it's looking very
unlikely but if they were to revive it
it's one of those shows I 100 would love
to see we've got Quantum Leap nobody
asked for it and we got it so why
couldn't we get Farscape
I'd love you guys to give for comments
to tell me exactly what you think is
Farscape a project you would like to see
brought back would you like to see a
hard reboot or like me would you
actually like to see a clever
continuation and how many puppets do you
want in this series I'm voting many
I'd love to know exactly what you're
thinking
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you will never miss any of our future
videos also you can go on to patreon
where I put most of our videos on before
YouTube so you can get to see it before
everybody else for a small fee and
without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign